AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
"BUZZFALLOUT."
YESTERDAY, "FALLOUT 4" CAME OUT.
I ALREADY ORDERED MY COPY ON
AMAZON PRIME! IT'S GOING TO GET
HERE FRIDAY FOR FREE.
IT'S A POST-APOCALYPTIC GAME
THAT'S SET EXACTLY ONE YEAR
AFTER DONALD TRUMP GETS ELECTED,
PROBABLY.
YOU DON'T EVEN WANT TO SEE WHAT
THE HILLARY ONE LOOKS LIKE!
OK, MAYBE YOU DO.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS.
>> GREAT CALVES.
>> CHRIS: IF THERE IS ONE THING
BESIDES COCKROACHES AND GARY
BUSEY THAT'LL SURVIVE NUCLEAR
HOLOCAUST, IT'LL BE CLICKBAIT
ARTICLES.
WE CAN'T LIVE WITHOUT 'EM!
SO COMEDIANS, PLEASE GIVE ME AS
MANY BUZZFEED "LISTS FOR THE
APOCALYPSE" AS YOU CAN.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
JENA.
>> TEN PICTURES OF SIDE BOOB TO
MAKE YOU FORGET YOU LIVE IN A
WASTELAND.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HARI.
>> 1052 WAYS "BACK TO THE
FUTURE 2" WAS WRONG ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. JENA.
>> 27 UNDERRATED ALTERNATIVES TO
EATING EVERYONE YOU KNOW.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JENA AGAIN.
>> FOUR KIDS WHO DON'T REMEMBER
WATER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. MIKE.
>> 13 THINGS YOU SHOULD'VE
LEARNED TO DO BEFORE THIS
HAPPENED.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HARI.
>> FIVE ACTORS YOU CAN EAT.
CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> EIGHT FETISHES NO ONE WILL
JUDGE YOU FOR ANYMORE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HARI.
>> THIS GUY USED TO BE TOM
PETTY.
CHRIS: POINTS.
JENA.
>> YOU WON'T BELIEVE HOW FAR
THIS MAN GOT WITHOUT
ANTIBIOTICS.